je vous fais un petit dru cas on va voir
s'il lui dit c'est une bonne nouvelle
quoi on va voir si vous êtes bon en
tables de multiplication celui doublure
celui qui si je le sors atteint mes avis
alors allez on va démarrer le parc
castaldi qui est très bon allez castaldi
six familles de castaldi si peu vite car
vu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
des mecs ces deux seconds films aspirait
retient pas notablement 10 mai année on
va vers 15 - 16 15 - 15 sept oui ces
bois mais bon sa part reflète le loire
c'était bien et n'ont eu quinze mois
cette année pour la saint jean monsieur
le maire
huit fois 7,56 à bromont jean mi
christine kelly 36 divisée par 3 je la
cherche pas réfléchi mais où en scène du
sel
bah quoi ils comptent en millions que
maxime brel c'est vrai mais vous savez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pas de précision le sérieux c'est mais
bon sang trois mois dit 703 moyenne ce
qui fait un faux
[Applaudissements]
apprendre à 17,86 été facile
novelli avait dit ça c'est pour vous sa
qualité d'eau venus de 16 m o
[Applaudissements]
non mais j'étais à l'école ça se fait je
suis mort y est mais n'ont fait que vous
hésitiez s'affronter s'aimer pour elle
mais m tracy je croyais que moi racines
communes au 17 mai je suis pas débile je
suis vexé par contre poupet vexé moi je
suis et je suis aujourd'hui
attention j'ai des racines carrées n'est
pas que bell mais merci c'est sûr elle
ne fait pas que rien mais ça fait de
plus en plus dans l'émission qui se
masque fait la gueule non je suis un peu
vexé mais ça va trop loin
une autre question et ses camardes de 1
c'est vrai pas les bras les quotas la
balle a bien répondu à la fota alors
sérieux américaine d'abord le bac la
tension gilles verdez 9 dont la moitié
de ce nice 9 3 5 4
bravo chillou non non non non non mais
un rapport aux yeux tu sais moi j'ai
choisi les yeux bien sûr ses yeux le
reste tu peux me tu peux me faire
saliver 12 par 12 144 bravo dit ah ouais
c'est les questions niveau cp quand on
va voir où ça va mais oh excusez moi
alors je fais quoi je reviens sur vous
sauve moi même j'en ai pas attention
jean michel maire bon bah non c'est
géraldine nom avait sauvé une fresque
voilà c'est beaucoup trop
jean michel mr tension 8 parmit - 6 60
60 60
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la conduite à 60 4 voire 6 égales 50/50
jeanicot alors dolce des courses sur
route est plus lent que les autres
il a le droit à trois minutes on peut
l'aider c'est normal c'est dans la
tension portable sonne gynéco danger les
côtes ou simple rien pour toi aller mais
on se trompe tout le temps aux minces
cette fois 6 56 dont la france allait
[Rires]
est ce que vous vous l'exploit de la
place de géraldine que quelqu'un aille
parce que je joue le jeu je suis là pour
ça alors bébé vous faut-il appuyer
l'attaqué alors que géraldine très bien
tu es bon tu sais lire taylor mais
attention n'appuie pas si c'est pas bon
ben si c'est bon je te jure en face mais
certainement mais j'ai pas alors j'ai
pas d'oreillette ce soir d'accord pas
d'oreillette ce soir on l'obligé alors à
lesparre n'ai pas 65 x 82 x
non non vraiment je fais une facile
c'est une possible nouvelle guerre
seront pour faire si la pelouse est bien
trop pour ça mais n'est pas à l'aise il
a prôné un truc qui situe à battre a
bien donné plein
ouais bah oui mais vous les avez
l'audace
[Rires]
allez vous êtes très bon bébé allait
vite à tony va quel est le tiers alda
les 222 x 3 222 x 3 666 tranquille
[Applaudissements]